hey everybody welcome back to koala zoo
and this is going to be a somewhat short
episode I'm just filling in some of the
empty spaces that have been left around
the zoo so far so nothing too special
but still some important work that needs
to be done at some point and as always
we've got Rudy and lady in here as well
how you guys doing good
all right it's it's not quite as fancy
of an episode as some of them are but I
think it's still some important stuff
that needed to be done so I'm starting
off here with a guest services building
which is going to come next to the
entrance in the actual pike file you
might also notice that I'm not actually
in the park file but that is for the
usual yeah it's becoming leggy and like
here for me and it's just not really
doable at this point anymore I'm
actually gonna try at the end of this
episode
to come back into it but it was just
unrecorded worthy it's like a lower FPS
than what I usually even record my time
lapses in so I can speed them up and
save on recording space so we should by
the way apologize because the last
episode we mentioned that Mike was gonna
take over this week but mike has a lot
of stuff to do right now for his job so
it's not even sure that he is able to do
any video the next coming weeks so we
just gave him like how you say that
carte blanche like whenever you have
time just scream at us and then you can
take the park but for now we just have
to live with the fact that we can't let
Mike fill up everything that we hope
people do or like exactly
so yeah that's why Mike is not here and
that's why it's not Mike's episode yep
so I'm trying to sort of take over also
his kind of job of sometimes filling in
these empty nooks and crannies
I was thinking for a while of you know
some sort of big projects to add into
the zoo but I figured it would be best
to just take some time off do something
simple and small that fills in some of
the things that have been left behind
some of the smaller parts that are empty
starting off with of course the entrance
area which aside from these little plots
is more or less complete otherwise
that's like someone has to do it exactly
I'm super happy you're doing it because
I was already a little a little bit
looking at what I could do next and I
was like seeing so many gaps that need
to be mostly like filling up gaps like
whether it's like it's small or somehow
bigger animal habitat or just really an
in restaurants toilets and those kind of
things we're actually really coming in
that face like to kind of wrap it up
which they'll can be like maybe ten
episodes away but we are somehow heading
there I feel yeah yeah I mean it I think
to two things first of all I think we
all need to watch a little bit the
performance it's okay still has already
fallen behind I mean it's okay I'm the
architect so I can at least get some
blueprints like this in a separate file
and just slap them in the actual part
file yeah give us some toilets
so wait you're adding toilets right yeah
yeah I'm actually adding some toilet
buildings here
spoilers usually I'm as a German always
like blamed for having too many toilets
I don't know what that is like a theme
that in in the theme park and zoo
community people always laugh at us
Germans because we have so many
restrooms in all of our parks because
it's mandatory yeah I don't I didn't
even know that it's like I think you
know are there countries I have no idea
I don't even know if it's true but it
really was like whenever I was adding a
toilets like are you Germans you always
have to toilet everywhere
like I don't know yeah it's it's super
weird so I'm happy that someone else is
adding some toilets now need to have
these things but on the bright side
though it I think it's not only wrapping
up but also I think we we all agreed on
the fact that we are hoping in the
future to see some let's say major
additions to plan a zoo which we still
want to be able to bring in mm-hmm to be
honest I don't think we're gonna make it
until we get like the I wish you guys
good luck my CPU is already melting yeah
but other than that like I think like
max of ten episodes I think then Cole
alley zoo is finished and you're not
gonna tell me that in ten weeks from now
well maybe we got a do you see what
could it be June July but I have my
doubts that that will be a big one
mm-hmm okay so we can confirm it already
because when lady lady has some doubts
we have to follow what my really
hormonal
I wasn't sure for the last you'll see
that one was kinda giving me more ideas
about the future of planet zoo like
obviously I can only think about what I
think that is going to happen but seeing
the last part the South America tag it
makes more than sense that it might be
in Australian pack or maybe some other
continent maybe it was see Anya or at
least not as big and I am hoping that at
least for like the December do you'll
see that that will be like a big deal
see with like either aviaries with birds
or aquariums or aquatic do you'll see
with like a bigger jump so ya know if if
if I am correct with this thought than
December no we're definitely finished
with koalas you in decent mood you're
gonna have to do quality zoo to Dan
because
you could have somebody again maybe
maybe we could do that like that could
be really cool maybe with if there's a
really game-changing things it's maybe
not even that bad of an idea I mean we
could always go into like another themed
attic approach like doing like a resort
style as we already kind of started with
like the beach resort as the theme park
now we have this jungle ish zoo but you
could always go like for example for
like a water park or like a birds yeah
area I don't know you know what I mean
yeah I totally different kind of
approach that would be also very cool
yeah already gives like a total
different approach for the whole zoo so
a different continent exactly now we are
sending this over to to frontier and
tell them that in the future they should
release a planet game that combines both
and they need to make this so good that
performance is good enough to feature
both actually all three parks in there
yeah oh yes and the point is so that we
can make a new qawalli part right that's
nice thank you it's gonna be called
Planet qawalli
[Laughter]
and the game the game comes right off
the box with 13 FPS on eclis though I
would love it like I mean it's so cliche
at this point but a game that combines
more than just zoos or water parks or
theme parks oh and one I mean that's the
dream yeah oh yeah resort planet resort
thing you know he'll be fantastic but
yeah and then why not just call it Kwame
yeah you know in frontier hour or we
don't charge that much for the life
maybe 10% of all total profits exactly
some stock in front to you what may have
really saved by the way silt that I
really like the front of the shop and
the corner you're working on it looks so
beautiful
yeah it looks in the detail oh gosh you
better not complain about pieces
yeah you're a so many amusing in-game
roofs at least I'm not crazy going crazy
in the truth
I've almost did it I was very close I
have to give a shout-out to sim tannic
and Ruby and actually also other people
in the brownish in discord but I don't
know exactly who because in the bro
nation this court there appeared this
idea of creating clay tile roofs with
bamboo pieces and recoloring them into
bamboo colors which is absolutely
amazing like they totally look almost
identical to these clay roofs so I
actually used some bamboo
yeah it's bamboo on the end there on the
cornices yeah I was also briefly
checking in I was like hey wait they are
not like aren't they pieces from that
great pieces and you were like tilting
them so it's bamboo ok cool
so I don't know who I need to shout out
for this exactly I just know that it was
at the time I believe sim Tanic who
tagged me and then people said well
rubies also done it and I'm not exactly
sure who I should credit for this if
there's a person who has proof that they
came up with this or who just knows who
came up with this please comment it down
below because I'm very curious but it's
a super cool technique like if you want
to build custom clay roofs use bamboo
pieces just amazing in general the the
flexi color bamboo piece might be my
most favorite item off the pack because
it's so versatile you can use it as you
did you can use it for like metal beams
you use them from the bridge remember
two episodes ago I remember that you
used them for your custom bridge and you
can use them for like fences you can use
them for
well obviously roofs as we just learned
for clay roofs it's really cool and
obviously air from bamboo so yeah but
well who are we to use them as they're
supposed to use I mean yeah they work
well as bamboo as well though don't
don't want to count them out for that
but there's just one of the most
versatile pieces in the game yeah I'm
really really
really nice yeah looks so good
yeah the general architecture of this is
just very heavily inspired by general
Dutch colonial architecture around the
world just taking those Dutch Gables
those typical decorations on the pointy
roof Gables that you find in Dutch
buildings and just using different kinds
of textures using these stucco walls and
classical details but all together it's
very Dutch kind of bringing in that
colonial theme again yeah I feel like I
love no I I think I really do dig that
style especially because it blends in so
well it gives a bit of colour a bit of a
warm atmosphere to be honest and then
pair it with some kind of foliage
thematic foliage like a lot of palm
trees and stuff it gives it this this
tropical vibe when just totally I love
that because this is exactly what makes
the difference you know when you have
these could to suppress trees now in
front of it so this could still be
totally like in the Netherlands but you
know as soon as you move that into the
zoo it totally makes sense in the
context and with all the Indian pieces
you used here for that for the you know
little details it kind of makes a bit
more tropical vibe already so I really
love that I have to say that I never
expected the Indian pieces to be so much
being used in qawalli I really didn't
see that coming but the color is just
works so well and the textures it's so
funny to see it's coming back like in
almost every build and you can color it
I think it's just because the the yellow
tint fits so well it's such a good
yellow muted color it's not like super
aggressive but it's also not like too
dirty and it's also not like too
saturated or desaturate it's like a
really cool good yellow tone for it yeah
and they're just pieces with really cool
details I find like they're pieces that
I use a lot even if the colors aren't
totally perfect for what I'm looking for
just because they have all these little
detailing elements and really beautiful
windows
and bay windows and things like this
that you can use in you know not just
indian themes but also arabic themes or
Southeast Asian themes if you kind of
stretch their context well enough so
it's still probably my favorite set at
least in the base game yeah it's the
mexican set right oh well I didn't yeah
I mean you always remember your own
embarrassing moments when nobody else
remembers them right but I could say I
cannot even forget like people created
an e mode for that you know my channel
hasn't a Mexican emote now and whenever
Jennifer or Joelle come into my videos
my server or whatever you you you are
safe to say that ten seconds later there
is a Mexican joke going up and again in
my last video and it's like everyone is
like wait are you calling it a Bratz
Panda oh but you should you should
definitely forget about that like it's
even the English speaking people don't
know what they say because I figured
that now with the capuchin monkey I I
tried to find a reasonable kind of
common ground how this animal should be
pronounced because people in the
comments were like I love the way how
you pronounce that I was like hey wait a
second am i pronouncing it so wrong and
then someone who works in the zoo came
to me and said like hey you need to make
your pronunciation work by focusing on
the chin it's like actually the chin on
your body it's a capuchin monkey and I
was like okay then people were like no
no you're focusing on the first part of
the words like capuchin monkey I was
like what is right now and someone
started to google for a lot of videos
and pronunciation and everyone is
pronouncing in a different way it's
insane like there's no common ground
it's in so this animal and so I'm like
whatever you call it it's fine and I
think this is the same with the red
panda okay
no no it makes sense someone mentioned
it and it's it's not about the E and the
a it's about the T and the D and then
the Netherlands there's just everything
with a D and a T and the end
sounds like a T and you have to say red
I think I think that yeah but we are not
used to it at least not in the
Netherlands so it's like super hot I
know are you making a custom roof again
wait a second yeah so this is where this
is where the tile roof technique is on
display I mean it's it's not okay
this thing has a lot of pieces but I
think it's a really really good showcase
of why the bamboo pieces are amazing for
a tile roofs especially if you're
getting into shapes that you know the
game doesn't have for a time uh-huh but
you are so good at making these
customers it's ridiculous really you
always do the same but I'm not able to
redo the same like know what I love
about this tile you have is that they
are always so super clean became like I
know how much of a pain it is to align
them so properly especially in these
little corners where you really start to
get more narrow to the top it really
gets some pain to align that properly
and not make it stick into the other
side and you know make pieces come out
and suffer because especially when
you're rotated and you just figure like
ten minutes later if something wasn't
right
but how always so clean they look so
clean when you do this and I really love
that it's always very finicky it always
takes a lot of like trial and error to
get them right with these ones for the
bottom I couldn't even get them right
exactly because they are still one meter
pieces it's a bit annoying to work with
but you know I also think it doesn't
have to be 100% clean it's always nice
to have some pieces that are slightly
tilted or like off-kilter or things like
this because no real building is also
perfect yeah that's true that's why I
mean just like but I feel there's like I
think what I mean is like clean in a
very aesthetically pleasing way I guess
that's what I mean
and not like clean in terms of perfectly
aligned
I think because you can still build an
implant coaster and plan zoo in a way
that the roofs still look messed up if
you know what I mean if you just don't
care about this at all they become very
like unclean and like really I don't
know they just don't look natural and
yeah what I really like about your stuff
is that it looks natural especially with
the roof color variations you know my
god yeah that's my favorite thing about
doing custom roofs is that you can
really have full control over the the
color of each piece so you can really
induce some color variation which is
something that you miss with recoverable
pieces unfortunately but looks super
cool like also with the little yeah kind
of whatever you might have frame down
there yeah I'm really looking like what
is this going to be oh wait oh yeah of
course yeah yeah so I guess he bows like
put a little sign on the ground here
with the idea of putting a Bandstand
here which I totally thought like yeah
that's actually a cool idea it's
something that you find in theme parks a
lot it's not something that I've seen in
zoos but no that's I mean this is more
of a resorts kind of deal anyways so I
guess it could work
yeah so yeah we have a little Plaza over
here with a Bandstand and then
surrounded by still need to work on this
in the future or anybody can take up
this job at a small seating area outside
where people can sit and eat
uh-huh and then of course we have the
toilets as well and the go P slash
building that Mike made earlier so this
is kind of a sort of area at the back of
the zoo where there's not so much going
on in terms of habitats or animals or
even general you know nature natural
environments but it's really just a
chill area where you can sit down and
enjoy some food and entertainments and
things like this that's so cool actually
I also go say I love that this now tilts
a bit more towards the actual quality
Beach style with the toilets and this
gazebo it kind of reminds me of the
little viewing platform you made for the
little lake in front of the volcano and
one of the very first episodes of
quality Beach actually it kind of
reminds me of that one yeah I see what
that's me it may not be long so but it's
really really well done looks really
great yeah it's not about the length
it's about what you do
[Laughter]
Illya will love it Illya will love it oh
yeah for sure
but yeah that's that's basically it last
time Mike was here to give me some
cinematic
videos but this time I think I'm really
just gonna keep it to screenshots you
guys will have to see you know what this
stuff looks like in action I guess in
later episodes but but my computer is
just not gonna be able to handle this
stuff it's already melting down at the
thought of it yeah
anyway that'll be it for this episode of
koalas ooh so thank you really and Lee
for joining me today thank you for
having her welcome and thank you
everybody who watched this video for
coming here today to watch this and
we'll see you next time on whose channel
again who's next
yeah if Mike cannot do next week it'll
be my turn
all right well we'll see each other next
week then bye everybody bye goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]